en el vídeo anterior mostramos cómo
calcular los costos de oportunidad y
determinar quién tiene la ventaja
comparativa en la producción de un bien
por medio de los datos proporcionados en
una tabla de producción o una curva de
posibilidades de producción en este
vídeo teníamos una tabla que indicaba la
producción potencial de dos bienes que
dos países podrían producir con una
cantidad fija de insumos en este vídeo
veremos cómo calcular el costo de
oportunidad y determinar quién tiene la
ventaja comparativa en la producción de
dos bienes utilizando la información de
lo que llamamos una tabla de insumos
examinemos esta tabla y analicemos en
qué difiere de la información
proporcionada en la tabla del vídeo
anterior observen que en esta tabla no
se proporciona la producción que los dos
países pueden lograr en cambio se nos
proporciona el número de trabajadores
necesarios para obtener una unidad de
producción la variable en esta tabla es
el número de insumos que se necesitan
para producir mil sandías o una
bicicleta con esta información podemos
calcular los costos de oportunidad de
las sandías y las bicicletas
en estos dos países y determinar quién
tiene la ventaja comparativa en la
producción de los dos bienes comencemos
con las sandías en el país x creo que es
muy útil contar una historia al calcular
el costo de oportunidad usando los datos
de una tabla de insumos cuántas
bicicletas podrían haber producido los
cuatro trabajadores que se necesitan
para producir las mil sandías cuatro
trabajadores podrían haber producido
sólo cuatro doceavos de una bicicleta
porque habríamos necesitado tres veces
esa cantidad de trabajadores para
producir una bicicleta esto significa
que por cada 1000 sandías este país está
dejando de producir sólo un tercio de
bicicleta sigamos adelante y
transformemos esto a decimales para
facilitar la comparación de los costos
de oportunidad entre ambos países
entonces un tercio de una bicicleta
significa que el costo de oportunidad de
las sandías es de 0.33 bicicletas por
cada 1000 sandías para cada bicicleta se
necesitan 12 trabajadores la pregunta es
cuántas sandías podrían haber producido
esos 12 trabajadores
pues está es 12 dividido entre 4 porque
para producir una sola bicicleta se
necesitan 3 veces más trabajadores que
los que son necesarios para producir
1000 sandías entonces el costo de
oportunidad de las bicicletas en
términos de sandías es lo que podrían
haber producido esos 12 trabajadores que
es 3000 sandías así que pongamos un 1000
aquí se dejan de producir 3 mil 100 días
por cada bicicleta producida porque los
12 trabajadores necesarios para producir
una bicicleta podrían haber producido 12
entre 4 sandías apliquemos un método
similar para calcular el costo de
oportunidad de las sandías y las
bicicletas en el país
cuántas bicicletas podrían haber
producido los 6 trabajadores que se
necesitan para producir 1000 sandías
bien habrían sido necesarios 24
trabajadores para producir una bicicleta
por lo tanto en el país si se dejan de
producir 6 entre 24 para producir mil
sandías esto es un cuarto de bicicleta
por cada 1000 sandías lo convertimos a
decimales y obtenemos 0.25 bicicletas
por cada 1000 sandías entonces cuál es
el costo de oportunidad de las
bicicletas cuántas sandías podrían haber
producido esos 24 trabajadores bien pues
sólo se necesitan 6 trabajadores para
producir 1000 sandías así que el costo
de oportunidad de cada bicicleta son las
4000 sandías que podrían haber producido
los trabajadores que se necesitan para
producir una sola bicicleta ahora
tenemos los costos de oportunidad de las
bicicletas y las sandías en estos dos
países ahora vamos a determinar quién
tiene el costo de oportunidad más bajo
en sandías y quién tiene el costo de
oportunidad más bajo en bicicletas con
el fin de determinar quién debería
especializarse en la producción de cada
bien tomando como base el principio de
la ventaja comparativa comencemos con
las sandías podemos ver de inmediato que
1000 sandías cuestan menos en términos
de bicicletas en el país y de lo que
cuestan en el país x solo se dejaron de
producir un cuarto o 0.25 bicicletas en
comparación con las 0.30 y 3 del país x
eso da al país una ventaja comparativa
en la producción de sandías
y como era de esperarse el país x tiene
una ventaja comparativa en la producción
de bicicletas el país x deja de producir
sólo tres mil sandías por cada bicicleta
que produce mientras que el país ya deja
de producir 4000 sandías por cada
bicicleta que produce tomando como base
estos cálculos podemos llegar a las
siguientes conclusiones el país x
debería especializarse en la producción
de bicicletas porque tiene el costo de
oportunidad más bajo en comparación con
el país y luego el país que debería
especializarse en la producción de
sandías porque puede producirlas a un
costo de oportunidad más bajo de 0.25
bicicletas por sandía en comparación con
el país x que debe dejar de producir
0.33 bicicletas por cada sandía y como
obtienen ambos países los bienes que no
producen internamente deben comerciar
entre sí y por medio del comercio cada
uno puede disfrutar del bien que no está
produciendo internamente a un costo de
oportunidad más bajo que si lo hubiera
producido internamente en resumen la
diferencia entre lo que llamamos una
tabla
insumos y lo que llamamos una tabla de
producción es que la variable que se nos
proporciona en la primera son las
unidades de producción que se puede
lograr y en la segunda es el número de
unidades de insumo necesarias para
producir una unidad de producción en
esta tabla los insumos fueron el número
de trabajadores necesarios para cultivar
mil sandías y el número de trabajadores
necesarios para producir una bicicleta a
partir de los datos de una tabla de
insumos podemos calcular el costo de
oportunidad y determinar quién tiene la
ventaja comparativa en la producción de
dos bienes nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo